I am from Cheyenne Wyoming graduated
from Hillsdale College in 2009 and I
just started a job on the editorial page
of The Wall Street Journal I'm the
oldest of ten kids so I've got this big
fun and crazy family that's always very
vibrant and and chaotic and wonderful I
was a bit of a bookworm but also pretty
outgoing as a kid in high school we
actually had a lot of opportunities to
do journalism the local news channel let
me kind of shadow their reporters and
take camera crews into the high school
and report on the goings-on from the
teenage perspective I'd actually gone to
before I went to Hillsdale Community
College for two years wanted to study
journalism as a vocation and get the
technical stuff out of the way and then
Hillsdale was to learn about the
abstracts to think about the higher
principles why I was doing it I think
with Hillsdale a lot of what we think
about is human nature and the ways that
power plays out in government and the
ways that you protect against negative
influences having that kind of
philosophical background I think
investigative reporting is a pretty
natural next place to go collegian was
wonderful I was on their news page for a
little bit I was their opinion editor
for a little bit we got to meet a lot of
people that I think have been important
writers but also really excellent
mentors to young journalists and that's
been something that's been a game
changer my professor is one thing I
always appreciated about them is they
wanted you to think critically they
wanted you to ask hard questions and
they wanted you to debate and argue even
when it was uncomfortable the foreign
correspondents has always been something
I've loved I spent a year in China
reporting on religious persecution in
the underground Church so when I went to
National Review I knew that was
something that I wanted to do and they
were fantastic about it they sent me to
Ukraine as Russia was invading in the
east to talk a little bit about their
revolution that had just happened and
also sort of what they thought about
that conflict I went to Iraq
shortly after Isis had taken over Mosul
was talking about once again religious
persecution but also what had happened
to women and religious minorities the
e-z these Christians there's no better
way to learn about these geopolitical
issues these international events than
going there it's it's just intriguing
and it totally changes your outlook on
the world
I'm kind of blown away too when the
distinguished young alumni award
Hillsdale has given me so much it was
such a formative experience I'm so
thankful to the administration and to
the professor's I had and so thankful
for the quality of education I got I
found it just humbling and also really
exciting because I want to honor the
college that's done so much for me
you